오늘은 조금 일부러 매운 맛으로 좀
갔는데 왜냐면 제 음모로는 이놈 너무
약하다 그래 가지고 [웃음]
오늘 팔고 이런 거 아닙니다. 뭐
앱스타인 이런 거 아니고 제 음모로는
끝까지 가면 공멸까지 가는 겁니다.
커밍투 알스 트레이딩룸 시작하도록
하겠습니다. 원유 관련해서 그니까
석교 때문에 이전쟁이 길어질 수도
있다라는 생각을 모두가 다 동의하고
계셔 가지고 요즘에 켜면 켜면이이란
이스라엘 전쟁 얘기가 나오니까 그래서
저는 사실 오늘요 정도까진 안 하려고
했는데 제 음모론이 너무 약하다는
평가가 있어서 그러면 내 진심을 말해
주겠다라고 해서 그래서 오늘 이제
영화 영화로 시작하죠. 항상 제가 본
영화가 다 떨어지면 제가 이제
출연하지 않는 걸로 하도록
하겠습니다. [웃음]
매드맥스 이제 아시는 분들도 있죠.
매드맥스 1은 제법부터 좀
심플하잖아요. 역시 이제 뭐 함의가
없어요. 그냥 미친 맥스 이런
뜻입니다. 그 내용이 그거예요.
매드맥스 1이 고속도로에서 복수하는
내용입니다. 차도 나중에 이제 시가교
이렇게 바꿔 가지고요. 딱 봐도 이제
폭주적 같잖아요. 혹회 혹회한데
35만 달러밖에 안 써 가지고 되게
영화로서는 조금 그 퀄리티나 좀
낮은데 근데 그게 매력이었던 거예요.
그 거친고 이런 것들이. 그래서 돈을
굉장히 많이 벌어서 조지밀러가
이때부터 돈을 펑펑 쓰면서 영화를
만듭니다. 매드맥스 2, 3 이렇게
원은 그냥 고속도로에서 싸우는 것처럼
보이는데 2부터는 이란이 혁명을
수출하려고 그러니까 이란이 79년에
종교 혁명을 하잖아요. 그래서
사우디아라비아를 침공합니다. 그래서
중동의 원유 시설이 파괴돼요. 그래서
원유가 없어. 그게 73년입니다.
신기하죠? 이란의 혁명은 79년에
됐는데 어쨌든 73년에 그런 일이
일어나서이 매드맥스 세계관에서 그래서
원유가 떨어져서 아예 시스템까지
무너진 거예요. 그래서 이렇게 개판이
됩니다. 그 호주에 원유가 나는 이제
벌판 같은 데가 있는데 원유가 나는데
이렇게 좀 착한 사람들이 모여서
거주지를 만들고 요새처럼 그래서
원유를 캐고 있었어요. 근데 이제
밖에는 이런 왜 옷을 이렇게 안
입었는지 모르겠는데 어쨌든이 폭주족을
넘어서 약탈하는 사람들이 있는 거죠.
그래서 여기서 보면 그 기름 한 방울
때문에 막 사람 죽이고 이러거든요.
그게 매드맥스 2예요.로드 워리어.
맥스는 밖에서 이제 외토리처럼
돌아다니다가 여기에 합류해서 나중에요
탱크 보시면 이게 유조선이거든요.
유조 탱크야. 여기에 기름을 가득
싣고 맥스가 이걸 가지고 막
도망갑니다. 그러면이 폭주족 같은
깽단을 넘어서 약간 약탈꾼들인데이
달라붙어서 추격전을 하는 거죠. 그게
최근에 여러분들이 보는 매드맥스 그
분노의 질주, 분노의 도로 이런
것들하고 거의 비슷해요.이 세계관이
지금하고 좀 관련이 있죠. 이란이
사우디아 전쟁을 해서 원유 공급이
불투명해지자 세상이 이렇게 변한다.
이때는 그렇게 생각했어요.
1981년에 나온 영화입니다. 하지만
영화의 배경은 1988년이야. 우리
서울 올림픽 했을 때 81년에이
영화가 나왔을 때 굉장히 인기를 끌고
굉장히 흥행한 이유가 있어요. 왜냐면
79년에 이런 일들이 일어났기
때문이에요. 79년에 매드맥스 1이
나왔고 81년까지 매드맥스 1에서
돈을 많이 벌어 가지고 또 영화를
만들어야겠지 뭐 후속탐 만들어야지
생각하고 있을 때 잠깐시고 80년
정도부터 약간 구상을 했겠죠.
79년에 이런 일들이 일어났습니다.
79년에 굉장히 많은 일들이
일어났어요. 굉장히 중요한 일들이.
우선 이란에서 종교 혁명이 일어났고
중국하고 미국하고 정식으로
수교합니다. 그리고 우리나라에서
12륙 사태라고 박정희 대통령이
암살당하죠. 그리고 소련이
아프가니스탄을 침공합니다. 79년
한해. 한 해에 일하는 종교 혁명이
일어나고 소련하는 아프가니스탄을
침공하고 미국하고 중국은 그 사이에
화해하고 우리나라에서는 장기 집권하던
대통령이 죽습니다. 그니까 사람들이
야이 개판이다 야 이렇게 생각
했겠죠. 그러고 1980년
1979년에 이란에서 종교 혁명이
일어나서 안 그래도 종교 혁명이
일어나서 원유가 안 나오는데 그 옆에
있는 이라크랑 이란이랑 전쟁을 하기
시작합니다. 1980년에 종교
혁명하자마자 그다음에부터 이란이랑
이라크 굉장히 강한 그 그 동네에서
센 나란데 둘이 치고 받고 싸웁니다.
이때요 사진 보시면 알겠지만 유전을
이때는 유전을 안 까고 이런게 없어.
유전을 무조건 까.
이런 유저를 까고 시작한다니까요.
그래서 이때를 이제 2차 석파동이라고
부르죠. 1차 석파동은 용키프루 전쟁
뭐 이런 거 중동에서 전쟁이 있을 때
아랍 국가들이 아 나 미국 이놈
새끼들 너네 원유 안 줘라고 한게
1차고 2차는이란 이라크 전쟁 또
이란에서 어 종교 혁명이 나면서
원유가 안 나왔을 때 이때 이제
우리가 굉장히 힘들었죠. 우리가이
얼마나 힘들었겠어요. 대통령도 이제
돌아가셨는데 근데 왜 이때 왜 전쟁이
있었냐면 사실은 이란에서 종교 혁명이
일어나니까 어 미국이 사주한 것도
있고요. 왜냐면 이제 내가 가긴 좀
그래 소련도 지금 아프가니스탄 막
침공하고 있고 그런데 나도 지금
베트남 때문에 바쁘기도 하고 그래서
이라크에 있던 사다 호세인한테
펌프지를 합니다. 사다 호세인이
순립한데 이라크는 시아파가 더
많아요. 근데 이란이 시아파가
잡았잖아요. 이라크의 시아파가
이란이랑 동조에서 자기를 무너뜨릴까
봐 사다무세인이 선빵을 칩니다.
그리고 중동에는 당시 바트당이라고
세속주의 당이 있었어요. 아랍 쪽에
세속주의 당이 있었어요. 바트당의
지원을 받은게 사다무세인하고 시리아의
아사드 정권 둘이었어요. 그래서 우린
세속주의야. 물론 우리가 무한마드도
믿고 알라도 믿지만 그렇게 신정을 못
해라고 해서 세속주의하고 신정주의
정치하고 싸운 대리점 같은게
있었어요. 터키는 그때 어떤 편을
어느 쪽 편을 들었을까요? 터키는
세속주의라서 그래서 이란이 되게 홀로
싸웠던 거죠. 그래서 당시만 해도
이란의 어떤 석유 생산 시설 굉장히
많이 파괴됐고 이때부터 이란은
고난에는 익숙해진 거예요. 옆동네랑
이제 정쟁 전쟁하고 지원도 못 받고
당연히 미국은 경제 제재를 했겠죠.
그래서 애들은 익숙해. 안 쓰고
사는게 익숙해. 우리는 안 쓰고 못
살잖아요. 샤워 안 해 못 참는데
얘들은 참아요. 그래서 이라크가 쉽게
먹을 줄 알았는데 이란이 이제 인내
전술이나 굉장히 나라가 크니까 어쨌든
79년에 이런 일이 있고 80년에
이런 일이 있다 보니까 매드맥스 2
석유가 없으면 이런 세상이 될 거
같다고 생각하게 사람들이 이제 보면서
아 이럴 수도 있구나 그리고 재밌어
막 보면 좀 그로테스크한 것도
나오거든요. 그래서 또 성공을
합니다. 또 성공을 해서 조지밀러
감독이 쓰죠. 3 만들 땐 좀 다른
얘긴데 요때쯤 우리나라도 중요한 일이
있었죠. 아까 앞에 보셨겠지만
1979년에 박정희 대통령이 암살
당하는데 박정희 대통령이 왜
암살당했냐에 대한 의모로는 아니고
이제 의문 같은 것들이 있는 거죠.
우리도 굉장히 많이 영화로도 나오고
아직 풀리진 않았죠. 그죠? 그 중에
하나가 이제 이것 때문에 그런 거죠.
890 계획이라고. 우리나라의 핵개발
핵개발 계획을 890 계획이라고
부릅니다. 당시 대통령이 핵개발 하는
건 거의 공연한 사실이었고 당시에는
거의 모든 국가가 핵을 갖고 싶어
했어요. 왜냐면 45년에 일본의 핵이
떨어지면서 얼마나 핵이 강한지 알게
됐고 그래서 약속들이 자기 자위권
차원에서 핵을 갖고 싶어 했었죠.
69년에 닉슨 독트린 아까
말씀드렸죠. 79년에 미중 수교를
한다고요. 그니까 닉슨이야 그냥
아시아는 알아서 해요라고 하면서
우리나라에 있던 7사단을
철수시킵니다. 여전히 북이 위에 있고
중국하고도 차이 안 좋은데 어 미군
빼면 우리가 큰일 나겠네 해서 박정희
대통령이 74년부터 핵개발을 했다고
알려지 있습니다. 그래서 이위소 박사
수학 천재신데 미국에서 수학 교수도
하시고 미국 국방 쪽에 관련이
있으셨다고 하더라고요. 근데 74년
9월에 귀국을 하고요. 그래서 약간
무궁학 꽃이 피었습니다 보면은 이위소
박사가 우리나라 핵개발에 도움을
줬는데 그거를 막으려고 교통 사고를
위장해서 누군가 죽였다. 이런 얘기가
있는 거죠. 다모론 이거 밝혀진 건
없습니다. 그리고 아니란는 얘기도
훨씬 더 증거도 많고. 그런데
74년에 그러고 나서 이제 미국이
너네 한국 그 너네 핵개발 하면 안
돼. 핵은 우리만 가지고 있는
거야라고 해서 포기했다고 알려졌는데
포기하는 척하고 안 했다고 또 알려져
있죠. 그래서 74년에 또 무슨 일이
있냐면 유경수 여사가 피살됩니다.
당시 영분인이었는데 재미교포한테
어이없게 피사를 당하죠. 그래서
79년에 결국은 똑같이 부부가 피살
총에 이제 우리나라에서 총 별로
없는데 총으로 돌아갈 수 있는 그래서
이제 이때 김재규 중앙정보부 부장이
뭘 믿고 이런 일을 했을까 뭐 이런
얘기가 있는 거죠. 79년이 일했다.
지금 보면은 굉장히 다이나믹한 세계
사였죠. 근데 제가 아까 그랬죠.
핵무기는 모두가 갖고 싶어 했다고.
그러면 우리만 갖고 싶어 했을까요?
아니죠. 이스라엘도 갖고 싶어
했습니다. 이스라엘은 아주 옛날부터
갖고 싶어 했습니다. 이스라엘의
네개부 사막이 있어요. 거기에 디모나
지역이라는 데가 있는데 거기에 네개부
원자력 연구 이제는 그냥 원자력
연구센터라고 해. 옛날에는 안
그랬는데 또 우리가 이제 사실 그
물량전으로 하면 못 읽길 것 같으니까
핵이라도 있어야겠다. 그러면서
프랑스가 당시 이제 막 수혜우나
뺏기고 이러면서 아랍베디랑 사이도 안
좋고 프랑스가 의외로 미국 말로 잘
안 듣습니다. 지금도 잘 안 듣지만
근데 핵 기술이 있잖아요. 그래서
이스라엘한테 조금씩 조금씩 넘겨
줍니다. 그런데 이제 미국 몰래
몰래는 아니고 그냥 하고 있었는데
미국 애들이 이제 위성 사진 같은 거
찍었는데 촛벌을 입수했는데 사막에다
뭘 짓고 있는 거예요? 그래서 뭐
짓고 있어요? 그러니까 이스라엘이
섬유 공장입니다. 뭐 이렇게
거짓말했습니다. 속았지. 근데 속인
건가? 속아 준 건지 모르겠네.
어쨌든 그래서 결국은 정확히 말하면
60년대에는 이스라엘이 핵을 보유한다
했다라는게 이제 사실상 다들 인정했던
거고 결정적으로 1986년에 모르데
차이바누라는 그 내부 기술자가
폭로합니다. 사진 찍어 가지고 연구가
언론에 넘기고요. 그거 알고서 바로
모사드가 잡아오는데 기사는 났어요.
그래서 다시 잡혀 가지고 18년형
선고받고 어쨌든 폭로해. 결국은
폭로해. 그래서 1986년에 이미 전
세계가 이스라엘의 핵무기가 있다는 걸
압니다. 그런데 지금도 모르는 사람들
많죠. 왜냐면 이스라엘이 인정도 안
하고 누가 물어보지도 않아요. 하지만
1980년도에는 공식적으로 이스라엘이
핵 보유국이라는 걸 알고 있었습니다.
그런데 약간 누가 가지려고 하면
그렇게 지금 이란을 이란을 때리고
있는 이유 중에 하나도 너 핵
가지려고 하잖아라는 거예요.
이스라엘은 핵이 이미 80년도에
있었는데 이미 있어. 지금 계속
있어. 여기를 얼마나 철저하게
관리하냐면 이스라엘이 전쟁할 때 자국
비행기가 전투기가 지나가고 있는데
그걸 떨어뜨려 버립니다.이 물어보지도
않는 거예요. 너 누구냐 물어보지도
않고이 근처에 있는 거는 다
떨어뜨리는 거 있는 거예요. 근데 또
애계도 1986년에 폭로했을 때
모르데 차이 바누가 이스라엘에도 핵이
있다라고 폭로한 그 해에 체르노빌
원전 사고가 납니다. 사실은 4월에
원전 사고가 나고 기술자가 폭로한 건
10월쯤 돼요. 이거에 또 충격을
받은 거죠. 그래서 이스라엘은 이런
핵 모성이라는 스탠스를 취합니다.
부정하지도 인정하지도 않고 누가
물어보지도 않고 미국도 릭슨 때 이미
있는 건 알겠는데 있다고 얘기하지
마. 왜냐면 내가 가오가 좀 죽
죽잖아. 왜냐면 나하고 UN 상위사국
다섯 국가가 핵이 공식적으로 있는
나란데 내가 이제 돌봐주고 있는 앤데
네가 벌써 있다고 하면 내가 좀
가오가 죽잖아. 그러면서 있다고도
하지 말고 우리도 굳이 물어보지 않고
우리도 사찰도 안 안 할테니까 그냥
좀 있어. 뭐 그런 상황이고 그 4차
중동 전쟁이라고 이스라엘이 한번
질뻔한 전쟁이 있었거든요. 요때
이스라엘이 촉이 확 밀려요. 그때
골다메이어 총리라고 당시 이스라엘
총리가 핵폭탄 준비해라고 했다고
알려져 있습니다. 그래서 화들짝 놀란
미국하고 소련이 야 더 이상 들어가지
말고 아랍들한테 몰리라고 했다고 한
얘기가 있습니다. 왜냐면 삼손
전략이라고 삼손 아시죠? 삼손이
이스라엘 민족의 어떤 힘센 사람인데
약간 데릴라의 계략에 밀려서 묶여
있었는데 신전을 자기가 힘이 세
가지고 무너뜨린 다음에 같이 죽죠.
이스라엘이 아랍애들이 이렇게 치고
들어와서 우리가 주가가 무너질 바에는
그냥 같이 죽자. 그냥 내 머리
위에서 터트리겠다라고 미국한테
얘기했다고 해요. 그래서 지금도
이스라엘은 90기의 핵탄도를 가지고
있다고 알려져 있고 최대 400기를
만들 정도의 플루토늄 재처리된
플루토늄을 가지고 있다라고 알려져
있다고 합니다. 어 지금쯤에 왜가 핵
얘기를 하고 있냐 이런 생각을 하실
거 같아요. 하지만 이제 뒤에 가면
결론이 나오는데 핵이 히로시마에
떨어진 핵만 해도 15k톤 정도
됐는데 그것만 해도 이제 지금은 그건
이제 핵 축에도 못 들거든요. 지금은
수소 폭탄도 있고 다탄두라고 해서 핵
떨어지면 정말 어디까지 부실 수
있을지 알 수도 없어요. 그런데
반대로 전술핵이라는게 생겨납니다. 그
핵을 작게 만드는 거예요. 작게
만들고 가볍게 만들어서 그 좁은
지역만 타격할 수 있게 그 이제 그
정도로 기술이 있는 거고 뭐 물론
미국은 이미 60년대에 가지고 있었고
핵 만들 수 있는 나라는 다 만들 수
있어요. 그래서 이제 전술핵이라고
부르죠. 텍티컬 한 번도 쓴 적은
없어요. 아직까지. 하지만 이제 쓸
수 있어요. 옛날처럼 떨어뜨리면 막
도시 하나가 날라가고 이런게 아니고
몇 수십km 정도만 날릴 수
있거든요. 그러면이란 같은데 사실
탄도 미사일이나 토마크 보낼 필요
없이 탄도 미사일 만드는 공장인 거
같아. 그럼 여기만 날리려면 전술핵을
쓸 수 있어요. 물론 핵을 쓰면은 그
방사능이 있지만 쓸 수 있는 단계긴
해요. 이제 우리가 인류 기술이 한
70년대 이미 다 했었고 다른 나라들
다 가지고 있고 공식적인 핵 보유국
나 핵 있고 너네도 다 알지라고
얘기한 건 다섯 개밖에 없습니다.
지금 딱 다섯 개. UN, 상임,
이사국 다섯 개밖에 없어요. 미국,
러시아, 중국, 영국, 프랑스 의외로
핵을 가진 나라가 다섯 국가밖에
없어요. 그런데 실질적인 핵 보유구
핵 있는 건 알지만 인정 도장은 못
받은 데가네 군데인데 인도,
파키스탄, 이스라엘, 북한입니다.
인도랑 파키스탄은 NPT라고 그 핵
확산 억지 조약이라는게 있어요. 인도
파키스탄은 NPT에 가입을 안 해요.
왜냐면 그 너무 곤조가 있어요. 또이
두 친구들은 곤조가 있어서 MPT에
가입을 안 해서 공식 도장을 못
받았는데 있는 건 알아. 다 있는 건
알아. 그래서 인도 파키스탄이 싸울
때 둘이 막 치고 받고 싸우잖아요.
거기 아무도 개입하지 않습니다.
웬만하면 할 만도 하잖아요. 그죠?
아무도 개입하지 않습니다. 왜냐면
얘들이 더 치고 받고 싸우면 어떤
일이 벌어질지 모르기 때문에 그냥
둘이 싸울 때 그냥 둘만 싸우라고
내보 가만히 이렇게 있어. 다들
그죠? 둘이 가끔 이제 막
싸우거든요. 근데 가만히 있어.
이번에 파키스탄하고 아프리카니스탄하고
싸울 때도 가만히 있죠. 아무도 편을
안 들어. 왜냐면 핵이 있잖아.
애들은 마찬가지로 이스라엘도 이란이
뭐 날려도 가만히 있는 거죠. 핵이
있잖아. 왜냐면 핵이 있으면 공격하는
건 그렇다 쳐. 어디 내가 이제
상대방 어디에 날리는 걸 그렇다 쳐도
들어가질 못하는 거예요. 정말로 막
정말 궁주로 몰리면 결정권자가 무슨
결정을 내릴지 알 수가 없잖아. 내
위에다 그냥 터트려 버리면 돼. 그럼
이제 거기가 스타크래프트 해 보시면
저그가 이렇게 와. 그런데 이제
저그가 막 다 내 건물 부수고 있으면
내 위에다 핵 때려 버리면 건물은
살아남잖아요. 저그들은 다 죽어도
그럴 수 있으니까 그런 단계다.
그래서 이스라엘이 이제 이란이 핵을
가지면 안 된다라고 우겨서 왜냐면
핵을 갖는 순간 엄청 다루기 힘든
나라가 돼요. 근데 되게 신기하죠.
다섯 개밖에 없다는게 핵 발전소는
진짜 많거든요. 다들 우리도 핵
발전소가 원자력 발전소가 많은데
그래서 우리한테 여전히 이제 제철이
권한을 안 주는 거예요. 어쨌든 그런
상황이다. 매드맥스는 역시 이것도
다릅니다. 매드맥스가 왜 위대한
영화냐면 미래를 예지하셨기 때문에
그렇습니다. 매드맥스 2는 이란하고
사우디랑 싸워서 원유가 원유가 독나서
원유 공급이 안 돼서 세상이 엉망
진창이 되는 걸 다릅니다. 매드맥스
3는 핵전쟁 이유를 다릅니다.이 이
세계관에서 다루고 있는 건 2003년
2005년이에요. 2000년 초에
핵전쟁이 나고 그래서 엉마 진창이 된
호주 땅에서 이제 사는 걸 그린
영화가 매드맥스 3예요. 그래서
당연히 이제 원유는 별로 생각할 수가
없어. 그때쯤에 우리 핵전쟁 났는데
뭐 그래서 이때부터 매드맥스의 어떤
상징이 되는 건 막판 추격전 차타고
막 쫓아가는 거예요. 기름은 없어도
어떻게 하든 어떻게든 이때 이제 삶의
질은 구석기인데 여전히 차는 타고
매드맥스가
굉장히 트렌디하면서 미래를 보는
영화였던 이유가 왜 81년에는이란
전쟁 뭐 이렇게 하면서 원유가 없는
세상을 다뤘는데 왜 85년에는 핵전쟁
이유를 다뤘냐면 83년 81년에는 전
세계적으로 핵에 대한 두려움에
휩사했습니다. 왜냐면 1983년에
그날 이후라는 다큐 드라마지 다큐는
아닌데 미국 ABC 방송국에서
제작해서 어 83년 11월 20일에
방영하거든요. 이때 1억 명이
봤답니다. 미국이긴 하지만 어쨌든
1억 명이 보고 나는 못 봤죠.
왜냐면 이거 그때 우리나라에서도 방영
84년 이후에도 했는데 이건 이제
애들 못 보는 거였거든요. 19세.
그 당시 18세였는데 왜냐면 핵
전쟁이 나면 이렇게 막 사람이 죽는
걸 되게 정난하게 지금은 사실 좀
그렇게 고하진 않는데 당시로서는 엄청
충격이었던 거예요. 사람들이 핵에
대한 두려움이 굉장히 막 고조되고
레이건 대통령도 이걸 보고서 핵무기
감축 조약을 더 가차게 하라고
지시했다고 하고 한국에서도 방영하고
그러니까 어떤 시대인지 알겠죠?
70년대, 80년대는 10년대는 맨날
전쟁하고 막 이사대전 끝났는데
중동에서 전쟁하고 원유가 모자라서 뭐
아포칼립스가 될 거 같기도 하고
그러다 좀 있다 보니까깐 핵전쟁
때문에 우리가 다 죽을 수도 있어라는
두려움이 있었던 시대였던 거죠.
매드맥스 그거를 기가 막히게 캐치해서
1985년에 핵전쟁 이후 세상을
그리고 또 일종의 표준을 만들죠.
핵전쟁 이후는 이렇게 될 거야.
그래서 매드맥스가 위대한 영화가
됐다가 다시 15년에 나오게 된
거죠. 그래서 1980년대 핵은
반지정의 절대 반지처럼 약간 필요하긴
해. 뭔가 강한 무기긴 한데 우리가
거부해야 되는 원제 같은 거라고
사람들이 생각해서 독일은 특히 심하고
독일이 왜 탈원전으로 가냐면 이때
영향을 많이 받아서 그래요. 이때
86년도에 86년도에 무슨 일이
있었는지 말씀드렸죠. 체르노빌 원전
사고가 터졌고 그 여파로 이스라엘이
몰래 핵이 있다는 걸 이스라엘 사람이
폭로했고 왜냐면 그 폭로한 사람
모르데 차이 마누가 54년생인데 그날
이후를 방영한게 83년이라고
했잖아요. 그때 29살이었어요.
그리고 69년 68 혁명이라고도
부르는데 이때 15살이었어요. 기존
체제에 대한 반항하고 기존 체제가
잘못됐다고 10대 때 주입받은 사람이
29년에 그날 이후를 봤어. 아 이거
해 안 되겠네. 그런데 3년 있다가
체료노빌이 터진 거죠. 그럼 나라도
까야겠다라고 해서깐 거고 메리켈도
54년생입니다. 그러니까 왜 탈원전이
갔는지 알겠죠? 이때 메리켈도이
영향을 안 받을 수가 없었을 거예요.
그리고 체르노빌 원전 사고는 굿소련
사람들한테는 엄청난 트라우마예요.
왜냐면 굿소련이 무너진는데 결정적인
역할을 한게 체르노빌이거든요.
86년에 체르노빌 터지고 나서
구소련이 엄청나게 약해져요. 저걸
처리하는데 돈도 굉장히 많이
들었을뿐만 아니라 소련이란 체제에
대해서 스스로 자신감을 잃거든요.
그래서 구동독에 살고 있던 메르켈도
원전은 나쁜 거라고 생각을 계속 하고
있었던 거 좋게. 그러니까 90년대,
2000년대쯤에는 탈원전이 됐었던
거죠. 그리고 핵무기는 점점 없애야
되는 거. 핵 감축해야 되는 거.
그게 저희가 2010년도까지 살던
세상이었던 거예요. 지금은 어떠냐?
ün 좀선 다시 균 3 개봉하는데 균
보셨겠지만 균에서도 핵무기가 한 번
나옵니다. 균 세계관에서 핵이
있어요. 대가문들은 핵을 가지고
있어요. 자기 가문인데 내 거 가지고
있어. 그런데 핵을 쓸 수는 있어요.
쓸 수는 있는데 사람한테 쓰면
사람한테 쓰는 순간 인간한테 핵을
쓰는 순간 모든 가문들이 그 가문을
멸문시켜 나는 협장이 있어. 위대한
협약이라고 협정을 맺었어요. 우리가
야 핵은 있는 건 어쩔 수 없어.
하지만 사람한테 써서 사람이 핵으로
죽으면 너는 그냥 멸문이야. 모든
가문들이 이유 불문하고 그 가문을
멸문시키겠다라고 한 협의학이 있어요.
왜 지키는지 모르겠는데 하여튼 하지만
균원에서 폴 아트레이드가 이걸 쓰죠.
자기 아라키스에 있던 핵폭탄을 써서
황제를 제압해요. 근데 그 핵폭탄을
어떨 때 쓰냐면 황제 주둔지를 감싸고
있던 절벽 같은 거 있어요. 거기를
무너뜨려요. 거기 무너뜨려서
모래벌레들 저이 큰 거 있잖아요.이
무슨 말인지 못 알아시면 둔 처음부터
보시면 됩니다. 이걸 데리고 가서
황제 군대를 쓸어 버리죠. 나중에
아트레이드가 황제가 되고 나서도 이런
변명을 해요. 나는 인간한테 쓴게
아니야. 나는 산에다린 거야. 절벽
같은데 폴도 황제가 된 폴도 만약에
인간한테 썼다면이 제재를 받았을
거예요. 하지만 어쨌든 썼죠. 그전의
가문들은 인간이 피해를 당할까 봐
인간이 죽을까 봐 아예 그냥 보유만
하고 있었어요. 가문을 지키기 위해서
몰래 숨겨 놓은 거거든요. 하지만
그걸 사용하려고 마음을 먹지 못했어.
아버지도 자기가 이제 하코넨이 침략해
오는 과정에서도 그거를 쓸 생각을 못
했는데 폴은 새로운 세대인 폴은
아트레이드면서 프레맨이면서 퀘사스
회더락인 폴은 쓴 거예요. 인간은 안
죽였지만 그래서 새로운 황제가 됐죠.
새로운 시대가 열린 거예요. 지금
우리가 살고 있는 세상도 새로운
시대가 열리고 있는 거라고 저는
생각합니다. 왜냐면 최근에 가장
최근은 이거예요. 26년 3월
14일에 데이빗 이름이 이래요.
섹스가문이야. 스문
자꾸 이상하게 생각하시면 안
되는데라고 발음합니다. 미국 사람들이
인공지능 암호화폐 차르 자르라고 이제
담당하는요 사람인데이 사람이 뭐
인터뷰 하다가 싹스가이니까 당연히
유대인이겠죠. 예. 이스라엘이 만약에
미사일 요경 미사일이 떨어지거나
이란한테 밀릴 거 같으면 핵을 쓸
수도 있어라고 얘기합니다. 공개적으로
발언을 하고 2023년에 하마스랑
가아지고 있는 하마스랑 막 싸울 때
이스라엘 문화유산 장관이 사람인데 딱
보면 알죠? 약간 이거 쓰고 있으니까
좀 강경판데 가자 지구의 핵폭탄을
투하는 것도 선택지 중 하나다.
이렇게 얘기합니다.이 얘기하고 바로
잘려요.이 얘기는 이스라엘이 내가
핵폭탄이 있다는 걸 인정하는 꼴이
되니까. 그리고 푸틴도 어
2022년부터 계속 만약에
우크라이나랑 같이 유럽 군대가
들어오거나 미군이 지원하면 나 핵 쓸
수도 있어. 우리가 밀리면라고
얘기해갖고 실제로 2024년에 핵용
규칙을 개정합니다. 예전에는 굉장히
타이트한 조건일 때만 핵을 쓰기로
하는 개정 내규가 있었어요. 근데
2024년에 주권 또는 영토보전에
중대한 위협이 제례식 공격이라도
만약에 우크라이나랑 나토근이랑 소련
영토로 들어오면 핵을 쓸 수도 있다는
규칙을 개정하면 있습니다. 그리고
북한도 2022년에 국가 지도부가
위험하다 그러면 자동으로 핵타격을
가한다라고 핵을 어떻게 보면 공공연이
얘기하고 있는 거예요. 옛날에는 아예
핵이 있지만 없는 것처럼 다루던 우리
세상이 이제 핵을 얘기하고 있는
거예요. 그래서 이번에 아까
말씀드렸지만 이스라엘이 이란을
공격하는 명분 중에 하나가 쟤네 핵
만들려고 하니까 나는 공격해도 돼라는
어떤 정당성을 얘기하고 있는 거죠.
왜냐면 핵을 가지게 되는 순간 세력
균형이 무너진다고 생각을 그래서 뭐
아까 그 다섯 개 핵 보유 국가가
다른 나라 모고 만들지 말라고 하는
거잖아요. 우리나라도 그렇고 만들 순
있어요. 사실 기술은 뭐 다 이미
50년도에 다 공개된 건데 만들지
못하게 할 뿐인 거죠. 그래서 저는
결론인데이 결론을 내리긴 조금 제가
뭐 지정학자도 아니고 그렇긴 한데이란
이스라엘 전쟁의 에너지를 팔아먹거나
또는 중동 지역의 패권 누가 중동에서
짱이야라는 걸 두고 일어난 전쟁이라고
볼 수도 있습니다. 실제로 그런
측명도 있고 그거를 이제 트럼프라는
약간 어떻게 보면 조금 다루기 쉬운
미국 대통령을 이용해서 마침 이참에
시작한 걸 수도 있는데 아까 보여
드렸겠지만 만약에 그렇게 했다면
매드맥스 2처럼 전 세계가 굉장히
힘들어졌겠죠. 옛날 기준으로. 왜냐면
원유가 중동에서 무슨 일이 터지면
원유 공급이 안 돼서 매드맥스 2처럼
되면 핵전쟁을 하고 싶어도 못 해요.
왜냐면 싸울 힘이 없으니까 서로.
그런데 미국에서 쉐일이 나오면서
중동이 저렇게 돼도 매드맥스 2처럼은
안 됩니다. 그리고 쉐일 원유가
나오면 미국은 바퀴 뭐 전쟁이 나든
뭐 매드맥스 2처럼 되든 뭐
아포칼립스가 되든 그다지 신경 쓸
유인이 좀 적어져요. 그러면 핵을
가지고 싶은 욕망들이 더 많아지고
정확히 그 다섯 개 말고 다른 나라
가지고 있을 수도 있죠. 뭐 우리는
북한도 있는 거고. 그리고 심지어
만약에 러시아나 중국을 압박한다면
그들이 전술핵을 쓸 수도 있는 거죠.
전술핵을 쓰면 그니까 여기서 아까 그
말씀드린 그 각곡 지도자나 핵들이
말하는 핵은 그 큰 우리가 알고 있는
그 버석구름 나는게 아니고
전술핵이거든요. 전술핵을 쓰면 이런
시나리오가 있어요. 누군가 전술액을
쓴다. 밀려. 그니까 만약에 러시아가
밀려 가지고 전술액을 그 국경제역에서
조그맣게 써. 어 그러면 그걸 해계
당한 국가가 있을 거 아니에요.
우크라이나든 뭐 우리 영국군이든
그쪽에서는 어 전술 써도 되나?
전술액을 거기서 막 쓰기 시작해.
그러다 보면은 일이 커지면서 나중에
결국은 이제 전략핵 진짜 큰 핵도
쓰게 될 거다. 그러다 결국은 탄도
미사일을 날릴 거다. 이런 시나리오가
있거든요. 그래서 핵이라는 걸 아예
안 쓰면 상관없는데 전술액을 누군가
우리가 살고 있는 시대에서 한번 쓴다
그러면 이제 주식이 문제가 시대가 될
수도 있다는 거죠. 저는 여기까지
결론은 안 내렸는데 결국은 이렇게 될
거 같아요. 이렇게 되고 있는 거
같고 사실은 이차 대전은 이제
열전이죠. 진짜 치고받고 사람도 좋고
한참 냉전을 했습니다. 대리전 같은
거 하고 뭐 한국 전쟁도 사실 일종에
대리전이죠. 한국 전쟁, 베트남
전쟁, 아프가니스탄 전쟁, 중동에
있었던 전쟁들, 뭐 대만하고 중국과의
어떤 충돌 이런 거 다 대리전이지만
전면전은 없었거든요. 러시아
우크라이나 전쟁이 있고 중동에서도
이란하고 이스라엘 전쟁이 있는 거고
이제 아시아 정도에서만 터지면 이제
전 세계가 전쟁 중인 거거든요.
그래서 저는 뭐 이게 의도했거나
그런게 아니고 인간이 약간 평화를 잘
못 견뎌요. 그래서 2차대전 이후로
거의 한 7, 80년간 큰 전쟁이
없었기 때문에 무기는 계속 만들었죠.
무기는 되게 정교하게 잘 만들었고
결국은 미국은 원하던 원치 않던 체일
때문이든 아니든 전 세계에 대한
그립을 놓고 있고 그러니깐 다극
체제처럼 되면 결국은 또 짜잘한
전쟁들이 일어나고 그거에서 이제
이익을 얻기도 하고 여러 문제들이
해결이 되죠. 전쟁이 나면 그래서
저는 다시 열전의 시대가 열렸다고
생각하고 그래서 이렇게 결론을
내렸는데 그럼 뭐 사세요라고 제가
만들었다 지웠어요. 그거는 뭔가 좀
너무 그런 거 같아서 이거 보시면
알잖아요. 이거 어디 건지 아시죠?
>> [웃음]
>> 누가 만드는지 알잖아요. 그죠? 사진
많이 보셨을 거고. 이것도 이제 뭐
드론이고 이것도 드론이고이 우리나라는
요런 형태 원전이 없는데 이거 누가
질까요? 그 건설사가 짓는 거고 드론
누가 만드는지 좀 보셔야 될 거 같고
이거 보시고 이거 떠오르는 주식을
이제 다시 한번 보시면 차트 좋은 거
그중에 사시면 될 것 같습니다. 제가
차마 양심적으로 사실 뒤에
만들었거든요. 뭐 뭐뭐 뭐 뭐 뭐뭐
있어요라고 했는데 제가 결론이
핵전쟁이 일어날 수도 있습니다라는
결론을 내리다 보니까 거기까지는
그렇게는 못 하겠더라고요. 그래서
지웠어요. 요게 제가 혼자 내린
결론일 것 같은데 아니에요. 제가 책
같은 거 많이 봐요. 책들 보면은
이런 시나리오가 있습니다. 좀
섬뜻하죠? 저는 실제로 그렇게 안
됐으면 좋겠습니다. 하지만 방향이
그렇게 가고 있는 거는 어쩔 수 없고
그래서 이번 전쟁 이스라엘이랑
이란이랑이 전쟁이 아마 좀
잠잠해지더라도 곧 다른 곳에서 분쟁이
일어날 것 같고요. 그렇다 보면
투자하실 때 안정적인 투자는 좀
어렵다. 계속 변동성이 커질 수 있고
그러면 어떻게 보면 지수 선진국
지수가 좀 더 낮고 선진국 지수
중에서도 종목을 좀 그러니까 우리가
그동안 지구촌이라고 해서 촘촘히
이어진 능동적으로 선의를 가지고
이어진 공급망 또는 통신망 이런
것들이 있었는데 이제는 그런 시대는
좀 지난 거 같아요. 그래서 조금
어렵다. 약간 불안하다. 그래서 이제
주말 되면 좀 불안하고 그런 거죠.
오늘은 조금 일부러 매운 맛으로 좀
갔는데 왜냐면 제 음모로는이 너무
약하다 그래 가지고 [웃음]
제 음모로는 이제 핵전쟁으로 끝난다.
모유 팔고 이런 거 아닙니다. 뭐
앱스타인 이런 거 아니고 제 음모로는
끝까지 가면 공멸까지 가는 겁니다.
그러지 않겠죠? 어쨌든 알포인트는요
정도로 하고요. 오늘 제 결론은 3월
말까지는 좀 보자. 4월 초에 다시
들어가도 늦지 않고 여전히 먹을게
많습니다. 그러니까 조금 좁아심이
나시더라도 조금 더 현금화시고 주식은
지금 마치도록 하겠습니다. 좋은 주말
보내시고요. 다음 주 뵙겠습니다.
[음악]